poorly acted scenes and motion pictures
aren't hard to find questionable acting
chops demonstrated by television styles
on the other hand can get buried a
little deeper among the thousands of
hours of TV broadcast every day but fear
not fans of the small screen we've
screened more than 50 years of TV
history to put together this
retrospective of cringe-worthy clips we
guarantee your gratification from these
painfully poor performances a frightful
fight legendary television screen writer
and producer Gene Roddenberry
created one of the most memorable shows
in history with the futuristic
science-fiction series Star Trek
unfortunately lead actor William Shatner
playing USS Enterprise Captain James T
Kirk often boldly went where no bad
acting had ever gone before
Shatner may be a sci-fi icon but he's
set acting back eons with this painful
to watch fight sequence even famed
American astrophysicist Neil deGrasse
Tyson weighed in and what's commonly
referred to as at the worst fight scene
ever I thought even by them they could
have been more creative in what they
imagined an alien to look like
fortunately this scene wasn't the space
explorers final frontier the original
series aired for three seasons spinning
off into an entire multi-million dollar
franchise proving that Star Trek wasn't
just here today gone tomorrow again
the nose knows bad acting sticking with
fight scenes I leave you feeling queasy
martial arts maverick Chuck Norris was
known for dialing up some stomach
curdling doozies on his 90s CBS show
Walker Texas Ranger none were more
unappetizing than this front porch
frenzy but you're going to jail
no way no more jail never a show known
for its awful brawls all of those bolts
surely bowed down to this disaster Chuck
Norris jokes aside horrendous dialogue
and tone-deaf acting often turned his
eighth season long primetime drama into
pure comedy gold the bad guys in this
fight scene will testify to it baby on
board talking about painful there's no
other way to describe the tragically
lifeless first foray into acting by
Bristol Palin daughter a former Alaska
governor Sarah Palin if you look closely
you might even see her cue cards
I can friend the school I came her
yesterday morning at 9:00 to go with you
oh I was out by 7:00 I left you a note
on the door last night but I see it's
still there two years after our own teen
pregnancy saga was revealed Bristol got
the acting bug she appeared in an
episode of ABC Family series The Secret
Life of the American teenager it's for
teen moms so I didn't get here on my own
of course you did you're the world's
greatest French horn player and I'm
yo-yo ma Palin's awkward cameo
apparently was a one-time acting gig as
she told he online I'm not an actress
I'll leave that up to the experts but I
had a great time here I don't think I'll
be doing any more acting in the future
yeah good idea
good night sweet kitty in the next scene
it's not even humans doing the dirty
work this time ferocious felines took
their faulty starring turn on an episode
of NBC's a short-lived 1983 series and
Manimal
just like these poorly edited cats
viewers turned tail and ran to another
channel
television audience instead of bytes and
Manimal with one of the most infamous TV
flops of the decade powerless punch but
acting racially insensitive plotlines
and largely uninspired fight sequences
gave critics enough ammo to give Iron
Fist 1st season a resounding thumbs down
Game of Thrones veteran Finn Jones
played iron fist lead the conflicted
martial arts expert Danny Rand goes slow
at the beginning critics said the
overacting sensei was played with cheesy
lines and clueless slow pays to martial
arts moves
despite abysmal reviews for its first
run loyal Marvel fans will get more of
the mum of the glowing right hands as
Iron Fist started filming season 2 in
December 2017 another Marvel misstep
originally intended for a late 2018
movie release Marvel's Inhumans
franchise was instead hastily pushed
into television production in 2016 the
last-minute rush to where reflected in
the show's boring sets and bland the
lack of character development
[Music]
well you didn't want to be king you just
had to be king it's clear here acting
throughout the series suffer too
especially courtesy of lead character
black bolts
since bolt is mute and only communicate
with abbreviated sign language head nods
and eye rolls dialogue in the show is
played with uncomfortably long silent
pauses The Daily Beast summed up in
humans succinctly writing this is simply
put the worst thing to debut on TV this
fall and the worst disaster that Mary
Marvel has managed to cook up we can
think of worse marble things but close
enough she's so excited whether giving a
silver screen sludge and showgirls all
overacting away on the small screen
Saved by the Bell veteran Elizabeth
Berkeley has proven she's a princess of
pitiful performances playing stressed
out straight-a student Jessie Spano
Berkeley wore her crown with pride the
much much seen stands out as the most
memorable and saved by the bells run yet
it was almost left on the cutting-room
floor
the original script called for Jessie to
actually get addicted to speed but NBC
execs wouldn't allow mentioning the drug
the network eventually okayed Spanos
storyline to switch from an addiction to
speed to a caffeine pill addiction and
Jessie's song as well as Berkeley's
infamous odd thing lived on
[Applause]
stick to the dancing sometimes acting is
so ridiculously over-the-top that it
actually becomes good again how much is
it it'll be $18 Oh keep the change
hi doggie we present the case of Alfonso
Ribeiro if you tap danced on Broadway as
a child and then moon walked alongside
the legendary Michael Jackson and a
famous Pepsi commercial it's safe to say
you can hold your own as an accomplished
dancer but when Ribeiro made his
transition into television acting some
critics said he had two left feet rotten
listen my date with Lisa didn't quite
turn out the way I planned preach hell
why not
Ribeiro landed his signature TV role as
Carlton banks in 1990 on NBC's The Fresh
Prince of bel-air Colton had a share of
funny moments but in this scene
Ribeiro took Colton's character over the
top like few actors ever have
[Applause]
luckily for television viewers ribeirão
returned to his dancing roots and his
hilarious Colton moves winning the 19th
season of Dancing with the Stars really
it doesn't get better than this
[Applause]
thanks for watching click the loop icon
to subscribe to our YouTube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
your lefty